little update nunu
yes I'm y'all
once upon a time in a while
wild warm
there were two wolf brothers living in
their home lair with their Papa wolf
they lived in peace until hunters took
their dad
and they had to go on the run let me
know if you want me to change anything
to do with the audio by the way I'm the
big brother discovered that the little
one was not an ordinary wolf but a super
woof
they discovered a secret hideout where
they could train day and night they were
happy
but the little wolf got very sick and we
had to move on
the brothers made it to the home of
their ancestors and the old wolves took
care of them unfortunately I'll keep
music in the background and found them
thanks for the nice comments about my
hair nowhere to stay again so they
decided to keep going south they soon
entered the old forest of the Giants
where they met a pack of stray dogs
first secret farm there's gonna be a lot
of your knee joint you worked hard to
stock up on gold for the future ah there
I think you know relate others like them
and everybody loved the little dwarf
here's the dog was growing up fast do
you think the dog is guys his power was
grown to the Little Wolf was worn more
and independent
he didn't sound very happy about that
the big brother hooked up with a cold
she doc oh yeah we did they had their
own adventures we got some fun
suddenly the mean farmers who owned the
land try to hurt the brothers the leader
of the pack was killed oh yeah turned
into a super wolf
and destroyed everything yeah the big
brother was badly wounded Oh is the
worst fake brother that was wounded you
didn't know where the little cub was oh
my god what I thought oh she and I'll
notice hey if 196 no worries if you
can't stick around the school
and they're cool okay so we're injured
and a little brothers conversing and
I've forgotten their names can you guys
remind me what that name it's uh thanks
Ron and you remember these things I feel
like we've been here before
gonna bring that don't play so
hey Shawn wait whoa I'm sorry is he just
like remembering things from the past
and it was a bad idea
Daniel no way it's all good
Shirley Daniel I wish I'd listened when
you tried to stop me from going with Ben
there's two pits it's okay Dean okay so
I guess they did find each other and
that's all that counts so why don't you
come get me Oh
I'm alone Shawn he's dreaming I don't
know what to do I'm scared don't get so
close to that edge please come and get
me
yes I swear
know how the hell I'm in hospital
okay well this makes a change from the
woods Daniel mmm Wow keep having these
nightmares since I came out of the coma
people look so different with different
hair okay there's a card
bouncing ball what do we do here Oh a
sketchbook let's sketch I can't even
focus on the page this sucks ass man was
in a coma for weeks blind and [ __ ] and
in police custody going to jail soon
wait what he's going to jail hospitals
freak me out
I hate this where's Daniel I'm scared
tries to draw to kill time this room is
like a cage but I suck now no depth
perception oh because he's only got one
eye
oh no that's legs no art nurse [ __ ]
focusing equals immediate migraine going
crazy in here I woke up crying special
secret agent Flores she's trying to bond
with me trap me or trust me so flux cop
still can't find Daniels for the
explosion so he's out there alone wait
so is he going to jail or are they still
just investigating whether he should
honor
hey the CEO and hey I wish I could say
your name I'm just gonna call you Mac
hey Mac and hate imbolg happy birthday
down your where ever it oh this is
birthday that's pretty sad okay I think
he's like slowly getting better though
he's so clear faces
Clarence Stevens sent me a letter so
lonely I read it twice weird how I
missed them so cool to hear from captain
spirit too
glad he's doing fine my Joey sketch
doesn't look bad so bad he's around
I wish I could hear cats play again all
their songs are gone but not a lot of
time together
Great Kills for what what was that what
is this immolation - thanks Eliseo hope
you have a good stream oh I'll help you
enjoy the stream okay so I guess we
can't sketch cuz oh no I can't you can
draw something must suck sigh oh that's
weird
got to see like he sees oh wait no I
don't mean to leave great let's try
again
right so we need to survey the area I'm
trying to remember how to do all this ah
here we go
human sexual this of course why would
you want to draw the TV that's pretty
boy
you can do this you can so hard to focus
how to practice way more not giving up I
can keep going
Joris staircase must be positive
staircase out of here
I wish I could find a highway to freedom
lesson
hey Jonathan um so in regards to
donations I think every stream I'm just
gonna have some sort of just giving
donation feels like so every other
thinking I don't know how long this one
we up for but until I decide to change
it to another one I guess but we did get
up to five hundred and ten pounds is
pretty amazing I don't wanna call Joey
this must be my punishment gruel okay so
this agent he thinks that trying to like
for the front him can't wait to text you
how am i today I am very tired I was
telling people before this this week
I've been super tired so I'm this is
actually my nap time I've been like
nothing every day it's been so bad but
hopefully this will stop me napping
today at least this room drives me not
shush shush I'm talking to the people
talking to something right how are you
change Kratz Stephens life is better
must be tough on Claire we're grateful
to find out that you're safe and awake
the police contact sedessa me where when
you have found unconscious we run and
also busy in the hospital but you want
you to recover ASAP the doctors say that
you've woke up from that coma stronger
than before the most important thing is
to find Daniel we're helping the police
anywhere we can they really want to help
find them - Sean nope
Oh what they do like the police do
hopefully this reflects well during a
trial we know this okay so he's
definitely not going to jail yet still
hasn't had his trial the most important
thing oh yeah we read that we know this
must be hard for you after everything
you and your brother Vince room you're
both in our thoughts and prayers every
day and night remember your family and
we love
we hope to visit you that's really cute
PS Chris insisted to write at Olynyk
it's touched Isler PPS he doesn't know
Daniels missing it's very nice that was
super yeah hi Charlotte Daniel I hope
you're okay I'm trying but I miss both
of you a lot when he came back dad isn't
better lately he says hello and we're
fishing now that summer is here we do a
lot of stuff outside now all the snow is
gone you should come back to see Beaver
Creek without the snow I'll be waiting
for you PS we need to save Beaver Creek
from SWAT bags that's it thank you Oh
Cassidy wrote us a letter yeah let's
let's make this one I miss care so much
Wow she wrote him a bloody essay she
couldn't write now okay let's sweep this
one i Lashon bet you're supposed to hear
from me I found out we were in the same
hospital from the police after they
questioned just and I was checked out a
month ago so I took a chance to write
and hope you get this
I wish I could say everything I want but
you never know who's reading this if
anyone else is really miss [ __ ] you my
heart is still broken never Finn's death
and we all can't believe someone with so
much life isn't here anymore I have
dreams about him all the time yeah he
was [ __ ] he was a [ __ ] but he was a
[ __ ] and our family
I truly hope you're okay after what
happened as for me I don't remember much
except the explosion that Merrill's
office and then I woke up in the
hospital with blunt trauma okay so she
doesn't remember oh no where she does
know about Daniel anyway where she does
remember what happened and well the
doctors call blast lung injury I I can
still play guitar and sing not that I
feel like it anymore but I miss playing
to my sweet compadre
you probably know more about what's
going on than me but Hanna
penny and I were released without
charges so why why is he charged and she
wasn't the police was stoked to bust a
farm of drug traffickers
than us gutter punks toiling in the
fields we asked about you and Daniel but
got no answers
so with Finn gone our real family is
roadkill
now we're going now we're just a lonely
trio train hopping it all over but it
feels like we're in a loop to nowhere
honey Hannah and Penny aren't the same
and we fight too much
I'm not even sure we'll be together for
much longer oh no [ __ ] changes right but
no way I'm going back to Hillsboro I
know you're going to trial soon of the
Seattle situation oh oh of course
okay sorry it's all just hit me like a
ton of bricks it's not just about this
they found the kids and obviously it was
the I'm just trying to member was it the
dead police officer and the beginning
was the police officer died I wasn't of
the neighbor or was it both think it
might be the police officer yeah police
officer Mahan oh my god no you you
joking right I'm an Android and tween
please tell me you're joking
if you're not joking please take the
credit card back and I owe your dad for
money you're joking I take I'm Way too
gullible don't do this to me but thank
you but done but no thank you if you
stole I'm gonna shut up Matt I hope we
can swim naked again under a new
moonlight it's a big world and maybe
we'll meet again someday 11-piece Cassie
she's cute it's thinking about Cassidy
looks like someone's getting tired - I'm
glad I'm not the only one super tired
old son so tired all the time as there
was a boy that [ __ ] zero depth
perception know him
goodbyes points
we could always yeah stupid reality
shows
now today Biasi watching some stupid
YouTube videos inside she's hilarious
alright you're kidding oh thank you
wait what what did I just do you're like
cool someone Joey must hate the sound of
this thing
Joey who's Joey Joey can I get out can I
move around anything else I can do
it's got nice eyebrows just want to get
out of here
good day sunshine hey Joey hey man that
looks like it might have been food hard
to tell
ha ha ha never heard that before
Oh somebody is in a bad mood sorry Joey
not feeling it today
mmm I don't blame you but maybe I got
something to cheer you up
pecans in chocolate uh-oh there's that
smile Thanks joint so how you feeling
today
any headaches socket pain now you talk
it well this is your final test before
you know before they check you out
check me out - Judy yeah ok let's see
you know the drill
don't blink and just stare at the light
can we just fake the worst or it now
sudden bills retinal response
okay now try to follow the light as well
as you can
come on Shawn you've been there before
good keep going quick response nice
remember to see objects on your left
side you gotta tell you ahead more now
yes
looking good Shawn now try to align your
PIN with mine I'll try it no rush this
is stuff I need to open up my window
your depth perception will always be
affected so you got to try harder [ __ ]
look my view this is actually kinda
difficult
yeah yeah I know it's hard come on hey
good job okay let's do it again damn you
hit a double today yeah mister yeah
that's enough too much stress on you and
your eye but remember your depth
perception will always be effective here
read this
I am a pirate why it what why did [ __ ]
pirate without a patch are I'd be more
worried if you weren't such a smartass
well I know it sucks for you bud it's
time we release you sorry your vision
has improved a lot
now you don't really have severe side
effects anymore
yeah that's just great I do have to tell
you the truth but first let's clean this
dress sure hope you're watching the door
like your phone come on
going nowhere I do watching yes true
your job this is the Asia
do you mind if we talk alone Munt if I
finish with my patient he looks good for
now right just come back when I'm
finished with him she's rude sure I'll
swing by later Sean
No miss you already
he's really nice
so how are you feeling today mr. Diaz
amazing did you find Daniel I want to go
over this again what I've been telling
the same [ __ ] story for three weeks
how much longer until it makes sense
until you get it right
so silence isn't gonna help you now
listen close Sean tomorrow you're going
to Jelena Shore and you'll be arraigned
in court for the murder of a Seattle
police officer you might spend the rest
of your life in prison or you can talk
to me oh no I'm such a goody two-shoes
I'm too good for this Hey not unlike a
you know I'm gonna make the wrong
decisions
I didn't kill anyone
I'm innocent until proven guilty I
didn't kill anyone
I mean I didn't kill anyone and I am
innocent but I think that's like aa die
for them unlike something someone who
killed someone would say I'm just
innocent until proven guilty
wait and I believe that that's why I
want you to tell me the whole truth it's
just a chant was doing your brother has
power no no way and you're absolutely
sure your dad didn't go after the
officer
yeah he came outside then he was killed
that's what he did just guilty of being
who knows I hear you but you're sure you
didn't get upset and go after the
officer it happens
Jesus oh look at me okay let's just jump
ahead tell me what happened in that
farming humble we have a young homicide
victim shot to death the place looks
like a tornado wiped it out I've told
you so many times
my brother's a superhero no clue why the
players trashed I passed out plus two
seriously wounded along with you and a
missing child
nobody sustainment matches with each
other
Shawn tell me a bone here can't you see
I want to help so you haven't found my
brother we might have some leads you can
help by telling me the truth okay [ __ ]
the robbery whose idea was it his or
yours huh
well it was fin it was fin I'm not even
gonna lie it was thin it was his idea to
rip off now did he force you to help or
did you go along with it
I'm such a goody two-shoes you lied but
it's very like but he got Daniel
involved
I swear swear I didn't think he lied he
would have never he would never have
told that he's dead until it's too late
yeah now I know
and what about Cassidy she planned all
this with Finn Cassidy can I keep this
she was against this stupid plan she had
nothing to do with her friend had to
learn to hardly with his life
I want to say my they didn't deserve it
but Fang didn't deserve that but this
was his song yes I'm loving the dad dad
died that's why they were on the run so
they have no one to live with but I mean
they didn't deserve dad because I didn't
think they were gonna get dad yeah I
will say they didn't deserve it
I didn't deserve him we all make
mistakes
yeah well some mistakes are worse than
others
by the way we contacted your
grandparents in Beavercreek they can
visit you after you're transferred you
might be a while but you do have a
support group we could interact on your
mother though sorry good what about
Daniel you said you had leads I said
might hold on I gotta take this call
wow you make Joey Leeds and that you
leave me before time and wait Daniel
adds you're such a little [ __ ] to be
able to these [ __ ] oh that's pretty
awful do you want anything to do with
this bet you wish you were back on the
farm [ __ ] sorry Hannah
hope the cops didn't mess with penny
person were to [ __ ] him out
wait what is she what she saying
[Music]
she's talking Spanish she Mexican too
possible
sorry about that uh he can speak in his
native tongue to her okay so what's
going on with Jamie
you really had leads yes we do that's
our job the bureau put his profile out
over four states so we are on the case
oh wait did I hear something you lied to
me you have no leads you have no [ __ ]
others I thought he just heard like they
did in your brother he's paying the
price I haven't lied actually [ __ ] you
I'm done anyway thanks for talking to me
I'll be back tomorrow to take you to
Jolene ashore
Wow
look out I have to God the God now love
it sit down so we can get this show
going so how did you interview with
Scully go
you mean interrogation who knows maybe
detective Flores wants to help maybe not
I just can't trust her after what you
and your brother went through I don't
blame you
this [ __ ] is all wrong man you've been
out of the garden for three weeks now we
talk every day I can see that you're a
good person
I don't know what to say but I'm not I
think he would say that I've let
everybody down
I lost Daniel and I'm going to Julie
this is all [ __ ] now let's check
this out Oh The Healing is coming along
nice just got to keep it clean for the
next week or so simple that's great
seeing the shrink this morning what did
she say
nothing I want to hear this will take
time and Rehab Sean you have to process
first up I can tell myself that [ __ ]
clearly I'm no therapist but I have
nurse patients with your injury
they all turned their anger into energy
you will too wait the glass he didn't
develop a power that hid things change
huh
I hear you
I'm trying to be positive but it's so
hard I know I do but I promise there's a
treat coming your way now ask for your
womb this is the last time you hear this
for me you got to clean it with sterile
gauze and saline solution
I wonder if it hurts anymore coke the
area using the swab and cream
then wrap it up with clean dressing hey
Blaine
remember you got to do this four times a
day I won't forget - I wish I could have
done more dude you saved my ass here
you're the only one I trust
it really helped cool I'm glad when I
can make a chippy ha shaped emergency
I'm out and no smoke break let's say our
goodbyes tomorrow Oh Sean
check out that sout got your name all
over it
catch you later Joey you are her boss
Joey's been Joey's the only one who
helped me get through this [ __ ]
pick it up remind you of doing
[Applause]
so drawing up in my artist trash now
can you not look at that
salvation lies ahead
okay let's look at the towel
what Wow haven't seen you in a while I
tell you oh it's a sketchbook
that's cute thanks Liam got my new
haircut so all I talk about
hey Wescoe I know I [ __ ] Daniel over
again
and now he's gone
where would he hide out
a ten-year-old by himself up there
you might go back to Seattle but too far
nowhere to go
if he tried to hook up with Claire and
Steven
they would have definitely told me
or the cops
maybe you would have gone back to that
cave what's that
super wolf is happy
it means that Daniel Daniels with Jacob
somewhere he's safe I could see him
again
huh
who's Jacob again I forget these things
I see the guy that gave us the dog he's
Jacob
coming up
it's gotta be someone from the camp
though right
okay
how do I get back Haven point Nevada Oh
Jacob is the guy that also had like a
younger sibling right he's like a little
kid he's lived in some malicious oh wait
what just happened
thanks for subscribing extreme gaming
yeah so Jacob was another person who was
at the campsite and he also had I think
it was like a younger sister he was kind
of quiet I gotta get to him it makes
sense why I didn't really remember him
it's true combating a way to escape
tonight
hey alejandro that's alright deaf thanks
for stopping by have a good evening all
day
okay
time to clear off now this whole
hospital is so quiet so don't make any
noise find a way to get the hell out
sheesh no noise I cannot make any noise
okay what should we look under the bed
for some reason why are we looking for
no no nedda ting should we take this
just the case thanks for the card agent
can't wait to text you you could open
the window we can look at the bedsheet
yeah so many options in this game you
boys shine in the bed oh we actually can
do something with the bedsheets
how's this one so no one sees what we
doing wish I could just walk out my
backpack it's gotta be somewhere around
here
they've been working on these rooms
forever so [ __ ] loud
sweet dreams
oh the God is right then maybe I can
trick him say I need an aspirin or
something
hey sir hello okay what's wrong now head
hurts I need aspirin damn it didn't work
he doesn't care about me I meant to come
in knock him out no don't give the cops
more ammunition to throw you into jail
I'm such a square let's see I just gotta
get past that locked door and an angry
guard
it's hard it's okay so now I can use the
window or something nothing in the
toilet nothing Matar they could hardly
see in here I don't want to end the
switch oh that's it must be a way to
leave this room without alerting anyone
I'm just peeing
this one isn't screwed in I could pull
it off but but what it's gonna be loud
maybe we shouldn't then I'm scared yeah
that metal bar isn't going anywhere
maybe I shouldn't do this
what's it look am I
yeah thanks for subscribing JG core
chorionic the video delay is insane so
dude look that cute now is this from
five years ago what I'm confused what
whatever we add on stands too dumb to
understand comfortable
we'll make a fake body yeah
all this ins it is how is it gonna make
it though you know what's amazing it
with like the pillows under the
bedsheets or something that looks so
fake it's bad nothing work for a second
no I such a badass alright I think
that's everything I'm not gonna pull
that thing off the wall because I don't
want to alert the guard you just
superhero to open that [ __ ]
shite oh no hope my last view of this
world isn't this window maybe it can
make one of the cars alarms go off and
then the guard go check the car I I
don't know one stupid car in America Oh
scaffolding I could slip into one of
those rooms under construction okay
tonight
oh it's dead tonight don't watch for me
don't know what to do I don't want to
knock that guy out guys I feel like
that's like the only way we can do this
leg but I really don't want to do it
I really can't open and open that window
with my bare hands
does it take something
is that it I thought I'd took something
I should close these so nobody sees me
sleepwalking away
yeah but still I mean what happens if I
use the cool I'd probably distract the
guard dog
we tonight maybe I could get Joey to
help me should i what do you get busted
I don't know I feel bad either one I
don't want to I don't want to get Joey
in trouble I don't know what else to do
and I don't want to rip that off the
wall because then the guards gonna come
in Oh shite Oh guys I don't know what to
do I feel like that's the only two
options here there really isn't it
Wesker this wants me to tear that pipe
but I don't want to have to knock out
the guard because then that gives the
more reason to throw me in jail I don't
know
Oh Liam thought was a nobody ever cause
of the delay no no no that's just my
internet I'm pretty sure my housemates
also like streaming or something as well
so it's probably that I probably changed
these stream nights just some way a
night when my housemate doesn't use it
as much he's just sitting there
see Wesker says ah this is what I think
is so long pretty handsome so I'm so
indecisive I don't know what to do I
don't want to make Joey lose this job
or something
am i drinking water h2o no one is
telling you what to do come I have to
make my own decisions well you are
taking my CV
they've said something contradictory
screw this through this through this I'm
not gonna get Joey in trouble so I guess
I'm just going to do probably the worst
thing I nice channel a dress weight
mantises there is another way are you
sure there's another way man tears
because if so then I'm gonna try and
find it I can't do this because it will
make too much noise
it's nothing to do here part them to
look at things
here my squeaky mouse real
throwing something out of the window but
I don't have anything to the row top
from maybe the pen like what did I pick
up from here again let's get
No
okay
it's just a souvenir what do I throw out
the window a letter wait wait these are
this is not actually my backpack how do
i yeah no that was my pockets
there is no extra thing you haven't
found pretty sure that's a double
negative but I'm pretty sure you mean
that there isn't an extra thing that I
have found but one of the solutions
doesn't lead to what you think it means
- okay so it is the option of either
taking something of the wall or foot or
phoning Joey Liam said oil it up oil up
with what must be
yeah final quarterly
mmm I just don't want to get him to get
fired I guess he doesn't have to help us
so he can say now
why wasn't nervous it's just the game
Joey
you do yeah
did I call it an easy kind showed you
showed you both do
did I do it
my just flopping around like an idiot
yeah I did it okay
this is my watch so excuse me
Hey yeah a there's my second favorite
patient you got you you never stop
working Joey I'm doing a double
nightshift
Diane is out with a flu so lucky me yeah
I'm fried but that sweet sweet overtime
Shawn you look stressed you feeling okay
and I think I could drop stuff I know
where my brother is Oh
I found a note in the sketchbook you
brought me he's in Nevada with um a
friend of ours [ __ ] Shawn that's awesome
now that's good news Nevada sucks but at
least the kid is safe listen Joey I need
to get out of here what come on Shawn
you know I can't let you do that you
know I'm on your side man I don't blame
you for being scared we're leaving
tomorrow but don't [ __ ] around with this
you hear me yeah but okay never mind I
just I want to help my brother
it's all I can think about she's ten
years old and out there all alone where
he's not because he's with his big
brother sure Jacob I wish I could help
you I swear I can't do this Joey please
no I feel bad now please just stop it's
not fair to ask me to give up my job in
my life yeah it's not let's stop this to
maybe possibly help you escape I know
I'm just desperate let's forget about
this okay I'll do anything else I can to
help now I really gotta get back to my
shift I'm tired already
no I feel bad now
I'm sorry Julie dummy I'm gonna do
stealing [ __ ]
hmm
too bad this isn't a movie can't even
fit
why sure why would it show me that uh
such a tease why is the game such a
tease I guess there's any one thing
today then mr. Brady nothing that I
could have done with that Pat whoa
nothing that I could have done with that
pan on so can just like step off from a
table
yeah so calling Joey didn't work so I'm
just gonna have to take it off the wall
I guess only I just I don't want to so I
feel like it's the bad it's the wrong
choice
unless he's something's changed out that
now since Joey's home
okay so I've taken so long guys I'm just
really indecisive I like to weigh up my
options very carefully okay
just do it
for kids I've already told one person in
this game
sleeping
where did he just hide that in his back
pocket or something
is he not is he not even bothered
no I'm not gonna ambush the guard that's
ridiculous
okay cool he didn't even come in I don't
have to put Joey in all good situation
I'm a [ __ ] yeah
hopefully this is my tuition toys
this is Gracie dude don't freak out just
get out
huh
and we dying at the end of the games
been great guys thanks for coming
don't think
just
keep going
Tom especially with one eye well take a
breath Jude
is he
it's cafe
we're too close
time to get my [ __ ] from the staff room
[Applause]
okay card is sleeping this is your big
chance dude
someone just let the door shut behind me
what's he doing
oh is that all the stuff in these 15 is
I maybe
he's a sneaker sneaker boy
convenient how he knew like exactly what
his stuff was [ __ ] yeah
he must be in pretty bad shape it he's
been kept here for so long no I'm not
gonna cry for you [ __ ]
yeah
it's gonna end up tripping an alarm if
she's not careful
lucky I was gonna say who leaves their
car unlocked I'm pretty sure I left my
car unlocked for like four days the
other week whoops
but it was in my private parking of like
thus like the flat by 11 so it's okay
I think Oh Kristen okay
well I hope Joey keeps the sink for at
least oh dude dude don't fall asleep at
the wheel
oh yeah because he's got a focus on the
road this is gonna be her he his head as
well
hey Lorenzo
hey Martin gaming PC I am on PC
yeah you did have to break out Jonathan
so he managed to stay awake all night
that's pretty impressive
[Music]
he's lucky that that car's tank was
basically fell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Nevada
[Music]
oh I thought he was like filling out the
gas and I was like was what money is you
have money
[Music]
I'm probably not gonna do the whole
episode now because I'll need like
dinner and stuff you know got work
tomorrow
I like these little wisps in the sky I
guess they're like clouds
they're not leave the battery on the
calf too long with the lights on you
have to bump diet
is he gonna sleep tonight yeah I don't
like what my eyes itchy
you should probably clean it before he
does off well he did take the agents
card come on
did she interview everyone in that
hospital what only stuff what kind of
stuff that they have he seems nice sorry
you stole your car guys [ __ ]
guess I [ __ ] up her day pretty bad oh
yeah she's got a lot of things yesterday
with the car and we took her go away
from her
[Music]
yes this is what I was wondering this
fuel and will never hole into a Haven
point yeah what a mess
Florida's can now at Grand Theft Auto to
my file
it's got a chitlin map I want to see how
close we are
okay slipping them out okay even pointed
straight ahead just a few more hours
time
where are we that's the hospital
was this where we are then this little
thing guess I maybe
okay that's creamy ice
all right careful
yeah don't jab it in
man I should have listened to Joey this
is a mess
what do you mean FC groningen is this
game anything like the series I don't
think there is a series is that correct
me if I'm wrong guess I'm kind of lucky
I stole a smoker's car
okay now what
do we go to sleep oh that's something up
here
mmm when is his car gonna run out of gas
still with me Shawn
yeah just zoning out
oh he's dreaming that when you're
driving my son
so huh what's the verdict on the new car
I know it's not a new board but it's got
port hot wheels thanks for finishing it
dad a perfect reward for your excellent
report card
I'm proud Shawn
you don't even [ __ ] me when you need
cash
and I'll try to be cool no dad jokes huh
I hope you're not too bummed out to go
on a big road trip with your lovely
papito huh please really coolest dad how
could I be bummed excuse me where's my
regular emotionless son I appreciate it
I think we can hang out for five days
without killing each other oh yeah
haven't done that since I was a kid nice
so do I so do I even if you hate to get
hugs from your old man I'm glad we're
here you know me dad
and keep everything inside good to hear
by the way boy talk
what's going on with that gym huh well
that's his old friend that he left
behind
well not much to talk about that was
like pulling teeth well I've got a week
to find out the truth
I'm a sucker she's a friend I don't get
to see her too much sure you are my son
no not like that like a friend could
that be Daniel hola hello
everything okay Lila Oh Daniel bear not
be giving you any sass he's driving real
slow and safe
like a grandma thanks for checking in
will buzz you when we hit the motel
oh no it doesn't mean this now the game
things that I like sounds pretty good
show ever
you think maybe seriously how are you
really doing so sad yeah I've changed
I'm so different now I don't even
recognize myself because you've changed
it's like evolution I know it birds big
time
yes I wasn't ready to change
I have total faith in news on your ideas
you were born to roam and find your way
home god I love you wish I would have
talked to you or you didn't have to tell
me
you showed me Oh bite the wage hey wake
up
no what are you doing on our property
man I crashed hard oh yeah come on out
boy who the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
I'm leaving leave me one I'm leaving
leaving okay I'll leave please don't do
this
no my darling they're already looking
for me I can't come any tell you okay
I'm coming hold on good now we can see
you to tell us what the [ __ ] you're
doing on our land and I just needed to
sleep I'm just I I just needed some
sleep I'm on a long road trip go for so
long guy I had to pull over to get some
rest you know I swear I had no idea this
was your property there's a [ __ ] sign
didn't you see it it's nighttime I was
too exhausted I guess I missed it
he's just a kid and he's hurt love ya
what happened to your eye it's an
accident caught into an accident oh yeah
uh-huh
move it oh [ __ ] this is bad guys no I
just want to go oh what's this drugs
yeah for my own oh yeah did you steal
them
no take his backpack dude oh [ __ ] I
didn't say anything
let's see what he's holding hey mistress
so nothing good any money don't take my
badge man you still play with toys
seriously it belongs to my brother leave
it alone
I don't know what to do I feel like we
need to assert ourselves here but at the
same time I don't want it to escalate
too much but at the same time I feel
like they're gonna be pricks anyway I'm
just gonna say goodbye [ __ ] yeah whoa
you did not
that's it boy get up oh so bad okay Chad
[Music]
you speak Spanish Pedro huh
what what what hablas espanol Chad so
professor how do you say I'm a dirty
thief
don't do this oh you don't want to share
your language okay maybe you know this
one
I'm a dirty thief with one eye
all right
I did what I did I want to do is learn
espanol might be our official language
someday right si Senor
so one more lesson how do you say this
is not my country
oh yeah did you hear that no dramatic
thunderstorm it's gonna rain
let's go before we get so no [ __ ] I
will clear child tree back go on this
little thief is [ __ ] with me you're
no on me off you know that but I'm
willing to give you one last chance to
make things right sure sing something
what just pass the audition and you're
free will be very upset if you refuse
he's making us look like an asshat
what do we do feel like maybe we should
just sing to get this over with and then
we can just get back on the road I mean
our brother is the most important thing
right now trying to look hard for some
[ __ ] is just not a priority but at
the same time he's just taking the piss
out of like ah what do we do what do you
think should I make him sing like I feel
like that's such a [ __ ] thing to do but
at the same time just want to get out
and see my brother
I'm waiting to see what you guys think
I'm went to the lab to capture the
Amarna refuse I hate that saying by the
way be a man but I see what you mean I
mean refuse is the obvious thing to do
but it's like our brother is the main
top thing and like anything to do to get
to him quicker right now right
yeah Liam's like that's a good point
Liam like what if we sing and then all
of a sudden it's like he's just like
amazing and the guys like whoa you have
such a beautiful voice and so sorry
okay everyone say Murphy's we refuse
No
really
I warned you boy
stop stop it chat off man
I hope it's enough frickin bad I it's
too much violence I don't like it
yeah holy cow what are you doing listen
you little [ __ ] get your [ __ ] and go
now yeah I wanted to ages ago
look just drive straight and you'll hit
the highway forget this happen man
okay
I hope we're going the right way
No
das is free pass
but yeah I am glad that I refused
so tha the wolf brothers were split
apart
the oldest wolf was badly hurt but
nothing could stop the wolf from
following his brother's tracks
[Music]
um this is going pretty hard still a few
hours away from Haven point almost there
he's over the last few hours
[ __ ] I need a break
maybe some shade at the next billboard
those things
scrap
oh yeah I'm sure there are people like
that in real life stop can't run for
miles in this heat
okay move reeks of shade no yes
shave
oh man hopefully we can hitchhike us I'm
that you're killing me I'm cold now it's
like hiking in hell
two drawers of them drink some water
oh [ __ ] I thought you feels like Sam
never drew a desert before
it's so empty and quiet
got a good picture of it I'm ready to
draw now
okay just draw now don't think about
anything else
this place is so empty at least I won't
mess up perspective for once I guess
that's an okay start I can keep going
got a good picture of it
I'm ready to draw now
okay just draw now don't think about
anything else
guess I could spice things up a bit make
the whole thing funnier drill hallo Joe
Asus limit draw hell I could try adding
details focus a bit more got a good
picture of it oh the thing man
my eye always starts hurting when I
focus for too long stay hydrated
exactly's um okay so I guess that's what
I could do down yeah
it's a coyote Daniel better be okay
feels like I haven't seen in years of
course I miss everything about him even
his whining yeah you couldn't wait to
get out on your own now you are it sucks
this is crazy
geez cops must be looking everywhere for
me right now there's something coming
[ __ ] there's a truck coming
maybe they'll let us on she's stopping
okay
be cool
just
see what he wants hopefully is gonna be
nice and asked us if you want to live
yes please too hot out here
and practically about to fall over
truckers can't be cops right
means weak arms are heavy she like you
around to the other side and ask him it
was I don't feel like I should be
opening his a door oh okay looks like I
have to hey you two left
yes me walking I agree
oh wait I can say no I mean no I really
don't think we'll make it if we keep
walking and the cops the cops are
looking for us and obviously if they
dislike to our process they'll be able
to see a straightaway but should we
trust a stranger
I mean it's gotta be something else I
happened if we say that we're gonna walk
[ __ ] it yeah thanks
hold up see not worried about our eye
very modest little place
loves America
jeez it'll happen to you thanks Peter
I ran into a couple of [ __ ] beat me
up for no reason
I see happens a lot around here
yeah what's up I had to make a [ __ ] stop
over okay he's not
don't freak out I I wouldn't have picked
you up if I cared about that hitchhiking
law something oh okay
somebody's not some weird serial killer
about to take us to some shady basement
hungry or what no hell yeah wait what
he's a shady [ __ ] one cougar room
with a ham sandwich
thank you as you heard my name is Anton
it is good huh my wife packs the best
sandwiches you know messy best sandwich
ever
seriously thanks sir Anton Anton right
what's your destination mmm
Haven point you've heard of it oh yeah
straight ahead about an hour
I know he lied but he said there was
like a law against picking a pitch I
guess so that makes sense
take a nap if you want you don't have to
stay awake to be nice hey don't worry
kid I'm not a [ __ ] weirdo just a
boring trucker
mm-hmm
he aims like smell them no you
I really hope he's not gonna take us on
some shady basement scan let's see
hopefully is just nice we've had too
many [ __ ] in this game we still have
some nice people nice people please
last stop even point okay just be
careful out here these people are kind
of weird really okay 10-4 good buddy
it's people are weird do we know
whereabouts in Haven point we're going
thank you
oh he was mice and he gave us a sandwich
of everything
okay this place is very religious I
think isn't he religious - oh come on
Beth uh-huh
forgot about Easter I completely lost
track of time
hope those people are caring Christians
like our grandparents yes so the
evolution I don't know if he is but his
family
you okay now is it gone I think good
scoot back inside now okay
hello there is everything all right yeah
yeah don't worry you here for the
service
I mean I don't feel like we should lie
not really looking for something don't
be shy
everybody's welcome here no matter who
you are or where you're from in his eyes
we are all equal plus we have a pretty
nice spread after the service stay as
long as you want okay thanks don't thank
me I'm just a vessel for our Reverend
thank her looks like you're here to see
our new miracle right what America what
miracle you haven't heard of him that I
won't spoil it for you he'll be here any
minute now just come inside and see for
yourself
is it done yours down you're the miracle
oh my god it's gonna be Daniel isn't it
Oh No yeah very young
that poor little girl coughs sounds real
bad her father was nice
maybe people won't judge me here
can't see anything guess it's time to go
to church it's gonna Brown Fest must be
more kids here huh wonder if Daniel made
friends yeah I'm pretty sure Daniel is
the miracle miracle child and they know
about what you can do for sure
Claire wouldn't approve Dan whoa
nice picture Daniel out here
wonder how many people come and go
through this place
smells like bacon and bread in there
[ __ ] I'm starving well they're gonna put
on a spread later okay
[Music]
wait how you sucking you just want a
sandwich like a giant slot machine I
guess it's probably not enough this
seems different anything around here
oops nope
can we go down there we will go in the
house eventually guys so should I look
around kind of time quiet
yep what's this place
maybe I can ask a bit more about this
place no one in I guess the wall in the
main bit
I wonder what kind of community this is
to Jacob really live you all his life
weird looks like our old training range
yeah Daniels miracle we just sussed it
found that the training zone should we
go in the back door let's go in the back
belong
oh it's not a lot of closed doors and
fences for such a small church
Oh feel that cold air thank God for AC
why should we seen up
a picnic was Daniel what's going on yep
Claire had pretty much the same ones
why are they talking about my brother
like that we saw a miracle child of
Jesus today I would not believe it
unless I saw it my very own eyes dint
knew I was indeed an angel sent down
unto us Oh No
this is so bad
but at least we found Daniel let's wash
off face her clean up first so I don't
scare Danny yeah you look pretty
different when he saw you last
eyepatch shaped head bruising you're
pretty badass so much better a new man
that's better than nothing I guess I
guess you haven't been to the toilet in
a while like do you need to go poop no
okay
I want to try and just see what's
upstairs fast oh I can look from up here
they came in a sneaky way but faith is
not just a word my brothers and sisters
Oh No what is this remember Luke 18:27
what is impossible for men is possible
for God with that righteous thing comes
the salvation of your souls can you
cross that invisible bridge to salvation
do you want your soul to be saved
brothers and sisters oh yes you are not
like all these sinners out there so I
never asked the Lord for a sign then
he gave us he spoke to me and told me
that I was doing right and to reward our
great faith the Lord sent me the
ultimate gift an angel a child graced
with the power of God the miracle we
have all been praying for waiting for
can I get a hallelujah
do you have faith in his power do you
have space in me I feel like if dunya
does anything they don't like the oldest
stuff say that he's like the devil and
the angel Daniel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
here is Daniel
he looks Saudis got Mullin to the Lions
buy pasta
yeah God saved Daniel so he could do his
work yes
Daniel was brought to me to deliver us
to guide us from the wilderness to our
destiny
now Daniel will reveal but she just
humped yet nowadays oh my gosh
don't do it Daniel they using you you're
a puppet
[Applause]
[Music]
your soul right
[Music]
now we have a voice a messenger filter I
said keep swelling I see more and more
new faces but this is only the beginning
you must see again the world looks
wobbly there witness to this miracles
thank you so much for coming and God
bless Oh
West Jacob
as our Reverend said we do appreciate
your kind donations this helps us keep
our church and to spread the word of God
oh yeah there's only a few tickets left
for our picnic wrapping next Sunday
don't miss the child with another
miracle any question bleep talk to me
outside
bless you for coming today
[Music]
hi oh hi I saw you having that parking
lot earlier
yep that was me I like to be sure to
they can see the whole room and it's
where a reverend mother teaches us
classes whoa you okay need some water
no sorry I'm just kind of sick oh that
sucks
that's too bad
Hey what happened to your eye
well that's a long story that's okay my
name is Sara Lee what's yours oh you
must be Jacob sister did you get that I
was with him that's how we met
you are a generous brother really she's
always talking about you yeah not too
well yes and Dennis brother
but I need some help there Reverend
Mother says we always have to help our
neighbor what do you need
what is this place this is our home our
church and community the Reverend mother
says we were all chosen by God mm-hmm
what is Daniel doing here
he's our miracle and the Lord brought
him right to our Reverend Mother I like
him he's really kind and funny we plays
together
oh he has a new friend that's cute who
is this
loving you don't know her that's her
mother listen she was blessed by the
hand of God and she was my age she can't
ever sin the Lord guides her that's
[ __ ] so can you take me to Danielle
oh yes he's gonna be so happy when he
sees you he missed you so much for this
birthday anything like a week's prize
Daniel you're the living so much money
and mine
daniel-san I guess
hey hey hey little bro
I knew it you've grown up at nine oh do
I look older what what happens your I
don't worry it's okay that happened
because of me I'm so sorry
okay it's okay it's not you forget it it
wasn't your fault I shoot him it's okay
well don't it kinda was but it's okay
don't worry about it not as much as your
hair good shut up
it's different I kind of like someone
but you don't want to leave you there
nothing I could do
I was so scared I even thought you were
dead
and it's okay we're together now yes
so are you gonna stay with us now huh I
we still need to go to Portland almost
but we don't need to we haven't hung up
not one step at a time
ding give Sean a chance process this I'm
sure this is all so overwhelming by the
way my name is Lizabeth Fisher we all
prayed for your safe return
Sean you must be a believer now in our
Lord too
not really not really no so Daniel was
wrong hmm you can be honest here Sean
but first I need Sara Lee and Daniel to
grab the medicine kit we have to take
care of our new guest this is a place of
healing let's do it later I want to talk
to him Daniel now okay whoa whoa Mike
it's a cult
I don't like it Sean it's a pleasure to
meet you this is a real blessing today
you were away from Daniel for quite a
while I was in a coma
of course I wasn't judging you so what
is your plan Sean this is a bless I
don't feel like it would be good I feel
like I heard to play her game you by his
side you should know that the Lord has
big plans for him
God or you god of course
I am his family two young boys are not a
family mark 3:25 if a house is divided
against itself that house cannot stand
daniel sounds more like a prisoner than
a guest it saddens me that you see
things that way after everything I've
done for him I know why you're scared of
Shaun that's because your hearts full of
sins
oh yeah for God you cannot say I'm a
lady and I cannot let a sinner like you
into my community
not until you make penance what are you
serious I'm sorry my son Jean and Daniel
isn't gonna be your golden cow Daniel
come on don't we ask him what he wants
to do not touch me what the [ __ ] what
did you do no not bad you spilled blood
oh so dramatic
your brother came in here impure and
acting like a criminal but here it is
you're lying it's a sin is it no I don't
notice what I meant that she's right no
crazy then we're ready
we can't she's trying to manipulate you
let me lead you to the one true left
that never goes out I want to be your
friend you're crazy
let's get out of here dude I'm gonna
stay then you know why you always making
attachments if they're fun times pizza
oh right come on get off I mean she has
look tough to him I'll give her that
Daniel let me go [ __ ] Daniel not your
family
stop it you just need to
have faith will be way Daniels okay Sean
Daniel
there you go satisfied now don't you
ever come back I thought they said that
they will be waiting
[Music]
do nothing
I'm just lay there like for [ __ ] you
then
I didn't realize who's gonna [ __ ] okay
sweet [ __ ] to me off it's a right
private I don't want to make it like a
nubbly around
I can't sneak back in after it's like
you I just
Wesker's like he Daniel is brainwashed
and what is this terrible next time I
will not hesitate to use this wow what a
man of God is it I love thy neighbor and
all that shite
is it Cassady wait who's that Karen you
won't get him back
let's go who's Karen
I was listening to Karen who's Karen
[Music]
oh he's had
poor guy he's been beaten up so many
times in the past like day maybe not so
many times but he's been beaten up a lot
Shawn what happened your eye oh my god
is that Shawn's mom what how is he yeah
why is she here how did you find me well
yeah cuz we think that Shawn's mum might
have the same thing as he said you were
missing Daniel and maybe that's why she
left them I believed in hmm so you
finally decided to check on it you know
Shawn sooner or later we're gonna have
to talk
are we even going
I already have a hotel you're gonna need
to rest okay
we can't be united with our mommies yeah
I reckon that said that she had the same
powers as Daniel and that's why she left
he must have spanked
hope he's remembering to clean his eyes
because those bruises
cute
man didn't clean the pain away but that
felt good
jeans go poop yet
damn
you were bad got to change that dressing
[Music]
Karin seems to be on the move quite
often
wonder how long Karen has been here you
see one of Daniels miracles
I think she's Nathan stop well maybe she
didn't know you leave this why she left
so Karen did check it out
wonder if she saw Daniel in action kind
of pretty wonder if she made it
I know I shouldn't peek but condoms
glad to know she learned the lesson oh
by road trip to get here
turning forward to look back making the
same choice twice twice my solitude days
and dreamy nights just to find myself
looking forward to turn back
oh she writes poetry it's cute
damn she does write poetry
oh she's creative just like him
tracing clothes every mile my heart goes
racing so I remember no the feeling
there's no fighting back that beating
and tearing apart my core early morning
blues coffee red eye chocolates and sad
family's bad eggs not the waitresses
fault she is a quick hard one probably
ND a long night shift tag says
Clementine 22 ish red hair dyed brunette
eyebrows and skin tone don't lie Irish
descent owner's daughter maybe Mahoney's
vague polite smile busy mind mildly
clumsy lips distracted anxious young
core cook caught her clammy brother
boyfriend boyfriend apologizes when the
orders of late and she's the one getting
wasted do mom and dad know you're dating
on the job climbing mixing up work in
love seldom makes a good match that's a
brand new baby bump and under the stain
date apron its 2017 and young felts
still busy making babies I guess nothing
ever changes I maybe she's a writer then
so somebody poem
I really should finish reading this
someday
sorry I still have no game and the house
always wins
[Applause]
something about soon
kans always into low-tech and even think
it's the one she had back then
those countries just YTV yeah America
it's bloody huge I went to Texas once
and we did a little road trip and bloody
hell just take so long to get anywhere
this place is quite remote
good base nobody will be looking for me
here
now I'm gonna drill them huh this is
your tablet
hey technology she came prepared okay so
she was really about the church I was
blessed as the pastor of our Holy Church
I have devoted my life and loved the
teachings of the gospel and our Lord I
was blessed since childhood should be
given this calling and it is my
privilege to spread the word and preside
over this loving righteous community of
Haven point I look forward to meeting
each and every one who seeks our humble
refuge together we will begin the
journey to a new life guided by the
Spirit of the Lord and Savior
Rick bless you all yes I don't like this
lady
I have forgiveness get rid of all
bitterness rage and anger yeah Reverend
Mother doesn't look too humble one of
the great mysteries of Nevada is how it
balances the Holy Spirit with the Holy
dollar few tourists travel from around
the world to seek religion here but in
the tight-knit Christian community of
Haven Point Nevada a charismatic pastor
has inspired as about following as she
told me in an interview at her peaceful
Church office
Reverend Elizabeth Fisher has spent a
whole life as a humble disciple of the
Lord feeling the call to share his love
and glory in the dark age I had a
powerful experience as a child that put
me on the righteous path I guess we'll
find out what this is eventually because
this is like very ominous she smiles
gently and touches my hand but this is
not about me or my story as anybody in
our wonderful church can tell you and
tell me they did the members of the
universal uprising Church but speak with
hushed or of their pastor and how she
inspires them Reverend Fisher just wants
to share her blessings with us as Cory
Johnson 34 a recent addition to the
congregation
I was pretty cynical before I went to
help one of her revivals you could feel
the electricity when she spoke people
are crying including me
looks like a roach motel but nobody will
find me there
more play must have party to play now no
okay Oh chef Nissa note
be right back we'll find out popped up
for supplies are grab food new socks and
shorts in the bathroom might be good
time to contact Jacob his number is on
the letter he sent Oh Jacob ah she left
us with some peas it only took Super Mom
eight years to give a [ __ ] mm okay seven
seven five five five five zero one one
eight
sirits wait authorities have gone you've
come a long long way buddy
this thing is killing my back I got
bruises on my bruises
this is some money
it's pretty interesting how like his
drawings were really good before I know
no look after this I they've gotten like
worse and I guess are gonna start
getting better as time goes on
there he is a little angel
nada don't want anything from her not
cans always into low-tech even think
it's the one she had back then wait how
we oh that phone okay
Jacob it's me Sean
is he not what the corrugations yeah I
know
I'm not far in a motel wait Daniel how's
he doing
Jacob wait
okay
wild mouse wild mouse son damn hope are
you gonna have to go through the data
always is so messed up
I'm so drained think that's everything
let's just rest while I wait for her if
she comes back
hey sorry it took so long [ __ ] store
was packed
how you feeling nothing broken
Walter boys don't fight fair yeah I'm
okay double cheese no onion right
that'll do
got you some gauze and anti bacterial
stuff your eye hey don't will fat down
or at least take a breath
like you care Shawn I do come on Karen
don't act all hurt it's too late where
were you when I broke my leg when I was
13 not with me
when Daniel got a bat flew a couple of
years ago he didn't sleep next to him
every night where were you where where
are you fair enough so let's talk
because we do have to get your brother
out of a cult I'm listening how did you
two survive alone on the road for that
long
where we go out we just got lucky and
got some help along the way
total strangers we even had our own
little family okay how did you go to
Beaver Creek you know I don't have to
answer your questions right you're a so
tell me what you want for me sure
nothing caring I mean what do you want
from me
a [ __ ] hug hey I just want you to
know what I did why if you care so ask
me anything why did you leave they go
all right why did you bail on us I
wasn't meant to be a wife or a mother I
thought I was supposed to I tried to
pretend for many years I wasn't happy
and the urge to leave just became
unbearable I had no other choice
are you serious you chose this life you
fell in love you made your own choices
right making your own choices doesn't
mean you can never fool yourself so it's
not because she had the same thing as
Daniel you were about eight and
Esteban's garage was getting busy there
was so much going on around me yet
somehow I just felt that my own life was
just slipping away don't like an empty
shell
Shawn it was the hardest decision I ever
made I knew I might never see you all
again but I took that responsibility
so you just dumped us so you could be
free yes Wow there's just so that's hard
to hear yes that's pretty hard to hear I
want to ask her if she knows about
Daniels pile down here no I'm Way out in
Arizona Shawn I told you your friend
Jacob wrote my P o box hence that Daniel
was in trouble that's it
Arizona holy [ __ ]
he's just lizards and rocks yes I found
something there New York didn't really
do me good so yeah okay think I've heard
enough I didn't have a choice Shawn may
only have one life and I didn't want
mine to be spent in regrets for years I
fooled myself thinking I'd find
satisfaction into what society expected
me to be and that was my mistake
I hope someday you can understand that
but I never stopped caring about you for
what it's worth I am sorry for hurting
you and Daniel and Esteban
that it's really hard I want to be nice
at the same time just think like you
can't you gotta think about these things
before you have kids I mean easy for me
to say I don't have kids but you know
it's it's not right I'm not we were a
real family without you well Stefan was
meant to be a father I knew he would
take care of you the way you deserve
cept he's dead we've got no one left
they like like maybe I should have been
nice up at the same time I don't know
he's within his rights to stay angry
just for a little bit at least
I honestly thought that she would have
powers and that she didn't want to have
you Sean whatever you want to say to me
this is the time let's just get it all
out me okay see what happens
so
[Music]
what did you do when you left where did
you go I pursued some dreams and failed
learnt the lessons I guess all this time
I tried to find out what really matters
which doesn't involve a husband and two
kids it does to lots of people and I
totally respect that just not to me
ah the Hertzian those things which is
what those naughty mother in life was
about right school job marriage that's
my mom and dad they wanted me to follow
their rules their faith
I tried but I wanted to find my own way
with no security blanket family religion
social norms it's just all about
security after all
but it all just looked like a sweet
golden jail to me I tried to escape that
yeah hope it was worth it
it was
for now I found my fuzzy world with
like-minded people I'm at peace with my
fuck-ups my decisions
how do you make peace with bailing on
your parents your husband and your kids
I know that's hard to understand I think
people should know who they are
not fake it for anybody
I mean I get you wanted to leave and
stuff okay but why would you ghost us
like that not even a [ __ ] birthday
card I just
I thought if I vanished you would all
move on but I wanted to contact you guys
so many times
I almost did
hmm but you wanted a clean break from us
I didn't want to be a part-time
pissed-off mother not fair to any of you
I left when Daniel was still very young
so he wouldn't remember me
as it no did she hurt him worse I can't
remember yeah I was in that buggy I'm
Shawn I know do you want to tell me how
you felt them
we're now
I felt guilty that we were into nothing
our emotions out
I hope I can make it up to you Daniel
something should I've been looking at me
by getting his ass out of that church
cult whatever so did you ever actually
miss us
or dad of course Sean
maybe miss your father he had such a big
heart
he could brighten up a rainy day I was
like this superpower but above all I
miss watching her grow up see how you
saw the world
I missed sharing these moments of fear
Shawn
yeah is is her lessons well sit without
you I don't expect you to believe me
what I mean
whatever you sound so careless it's like
you can't even realize how much pain
you've cost they do care that's why I'm
here to help you and your brother if I
didn't step up to help him now
I couldn't live with myself
I think I think this dream stopped like
unless you guys aren't talking that's
fine but I think restream isn't showing
the cha anymore I don't know it did tell
me that it was having some issues with
chat right now but yeah if I'm not
replying to anyone in the charts
probably because I can't see your
messages long ago oh we didn't fly see
change right when we did I would go out
on the porch and write up it's like calm
down Esteban would come over and ask for
a draft then would just look up at the
sky watch the stars with planes
I do miss that I used to do the same my
best friend like sitting on the porch
just let him tango that's when you know
someone's good too
and you can just sit together
shut the hell up watch the universe do
its own thing
[Music]
it is nice I mean I do think hearing all
that from her it's like that's gonna be
really hard ta from a parent that they
gave you up and they don't work write it
but as I said at least she stepped me up
now so we should go back yes
I gotta change this dressing okay
finally clean up or I will be needing
this for ages Sean I know I can't change
the past for what I did but this is
about helping your brother you gotta
trust me this one time
yeah okay okay I've come around I'll
come around I know
it's still hard but yes we have to be a
team to rescue Daniel we can do it for
Daniel okay
ah
we need to get in touch with this Jakob
he obviously knows a lot more than us
about the church well I called him when
you're around we can meet with him
tomorrow okay good I also got these just
in case
okay
better take care of the I so do you
oh [ __ ] yes I probably do it hasn't had
a good cleaning out since Joey she is no
Joey but she will do can I see the aiya
yeah
here try this on
she get him an astral eye patch okay
that's pretty cool
are you meeting like a car right thank
you Ken big day tomorrow so we should
get some rest yeah I'm ready to get
Daniel
so yeah I I don't know what's up with
the stream I don't know if I'm just not
getting your comments or whether I'm not
even streaming on YouTube anymore says I
still have 18 viewers though
oh we're waiting for him sure he's gonna
show up
he better he promised an angry virus
what if he doesn't find us we'll find
him I can't believe how much crap you
guys have been through
makes me want to punch in the face each
and every [ __ ] that got me away yes
mama Kara's most amazing people - that's
right my friend the road is all about
that sweet encounters hope I can see
them again someday
oh well so tell me about Daniel what's
he like one sec I'm just gonna
double-check this whoa what's happening
oh yeah I am still I think I can get it
okay
I'm still streaming at least I just come
not ton not see the chat that's fine
I'll be finishing soon anyway just say
all the time I'll be finishing suits um
what should I say article okay that's
fair
Jenny wanted to grow up so fast it's
good you were there for him
it's up
is that him yep wait here
Shawn what happened
your crazy cult that's what happened I'm
looking at y'all angry and I'm not mad
but you better explain everything I
didn't know where else to go
listen I I saw Daniel come back to the
camp that night like he was in shock or
something then I heard all these sirens
and I got scared I just I packed a few
things I took a blanket from your tent
and we left together
I also kept the cash she made on the
farm
it's in my car you did right Jake thank
you
you have no idea what he looked like
when I found him that night Sean he was
in bad shape
shocked and mute and all by himself I
couldn't just leave him there
what about the others and penny what
happened to them they they ran over to
marrows place when they found out
finding Cass were gone that was the last
time I saw them then on their way out
here Daniel told me more about what
happened that night
Finn's murder
the blast Daniel feels he's got to
redeem himself
oh okay this is why it's only been so
easily manipulated he's not guilty of
anything
I should have protected him better I did
tell him that I did say it wasn't as
powerful so that was a good thing she's
waited her whole life for somebody like
Daniel the Reverend knows how to
manipulate people she's good at this
oh yeah he wants to stay with her daniel
has faith in the Reverend now
I believe Jacob not afraid of that
Lisbeth of yours I'm getting Daniel out
of here come on there's no way they're
gonna let you take him away look too bad
we're not gonna ask for their permission
you must be Jacob I'm Karen hi okay I
don't know if you want to do this but I
have an idea okay must be over by now
but Elizabeth will stay at the church
with Daniel for his special classes
that'll give us time to sneak into the
compound before we get to them I'll be
on the lookout keep watch in case it all
goes to [ __ ] Sean stay on the walkie
sounds like a plan
one more thing I we have to get my
sister to Sarah Lee really Jacob come on
man she's with your parents I know
please listen Sean she's not safe here
she's sick they believed in everything
Elizabeth says she says she'll cure
Sarah with right so she's not gonna be
medicine you understand right Tim Jake
we need his help - Sean
okay Jake I'm listening
Lizbeth knows what's wrong with Sara Lee
we just we need to find her medical
record I think it's in her office then
I'll go get Sara Lee while you get
Daniel okay fine sure I'm gonna trust
you on this Jake oh well good for you
Karen
what if Daniel won't go with you you
will I know him yeah I hope so I mean I
think we said the right thing to him
when we saw him last
we told him it wasn't his fault and if
he's feeling guilty and Mikey needs to
repent and hopefully hearing that after
a while he reflects on it I'll make it
easier
we shall sing
Karen
got it Thanks we gotta be careful now
if anything happens let me do the
talking okay
yeah of course all right let's get this
over with this is where I am going to
exit once again I don't know what's
happening with the chat but thank you so
much for spending the evening with me we
will play this again I know probably a
lot of you won it bees play like the
Last of Us because that comes out
tomorrow but I don't have it on
pre-order so maybe I'll do like first
impressions or something in the future
but for now I I'm sorry but I can play
more with this so you know you're not
gonna be on your own and more videos are
coming out in the future as well have
some more videos on the way um don't
forget you can check out my latest song
on most music streaming platforms so
just search Jack my necks and you can
hear my latest punk rock song which is
started off as a joke and ended up being
very serious and join the discord as
well hopefully you guys will be able to
get messages that I put in even if I
can't see what you write back because
I'm gonna send you a little a little
invite to the discord it's just kind of
like where we chat but also you get
announcements for new videos when I'm
streaming so by that I mean if you don't
have discord that's fine too you can
always just make sure you pressing the
bell and you will get notified of course
expired never I wish I could just change
I can probably change the server invoice
settings but default settings but right
[Music]
today okay
enjoy that it's good server suite okay
I'm gonna go now
have a lovely day or evening thanks
again for spending the evening with me
and yeah I'll see